a fox news exclusive republicans on the
house select subcommittee on kovid
released a report today exposing how the
cdc coordinated with the teachers unions
to slow the school reopening process
emails between the aft the biden white
house and the cdc show that the bite
administration's political leadership at
the cdc positioned the union to impose
line-by-line edits
to the reopening guidance
so how do you obtain such sway well in
2020 99.9
of the aft's donations went to democrats
nearly 1 million dollars republicans got
75
and that was from an employee
of the uh 25 biggest recipients of aft
cash four are democratic senators up for
re-election in toss-ups rafael warnock
of georgia mark kelly of arizona
catherine cortez masto of nevada and
maggie hassan sneaky in new hampshire
here now is the top republican on that
coveted subcommittee house minority whip
steve scalise
congress spend this level of
coordination
between the democrats
and teachers unions who have them in
their back pocket
this is not science this is politics
yeah laura and what we exposed through
this is that it was political science
not medical science that cdc used to put
their guidance out on school reopenings
and in fact cdc was getting ready to
come out with guidance that would have
been more
favorable towards opening schools and
then the teachers unions were given
weeks over over a week before it came
out we're given a sneak copy of it that
no one else got that we've been able to
find uh and said okay what do you think
about this and we had uncovered emails
between the cdc director and the union
president saying wait a minute we don't
like this we want new language that
makes it easier to close schools and
they actually the unions gave different
language to the cdc and in cdc's final
language was almost word for word
verbatim from what the teachers union
sent i don't know of any other group
surely no parents groups that got this
kind of vip access and in fact i asked
the cdc director today in the hearing to
give me a list of anybody else that they
gave this kind of access to to change
the documents we have one of your
exchanges this is when um you asked
walensky about the cdc's just plain
involvement with the unions watch these
were discussions that happened in the
beginning of february of 2021 days after
i entered into this position we needed
to get our schools open we in that
context
engage as we often do with organizations
and groups that are impacted by our
guidance and our recommendations at the
agency
first of all she's reading her response
she knows she's in hot water so she's
you can see her reading it
and second of all i mean
the teachers unions we know from the
chicago experience congressman they
never want to go back they if they could
stay remote forever
the unions
would would be happy to statement just
like your colleagues never want to come
back to do actual voting in person
so why would we ever ask for their
guidance since they don't want to come
back to work
right and ultimately what they said was
we want stronger guidance to keep
schools closed to keep millions of
children out of schools and keep in mind
too laura this is all going on under the
backdrop when the justice department is
calling parents domestic terrorists for
showing up at school board meetings so i
asked the cdc director give me names of
parent groups that you consulted and
gave the same kind of vp act vip access
they couldn't give me a name and i said
yeah i want to know like were parents
allowed to have the same kind of ability
to change the science like the unions
were able to get to keep schools closed
and she couldn't give me a single name
because it was the union bosses who said
look don't come out with this until you
give us new ability to shut down schools
and they paid off their friends and gave
them the language well i will say in
closing that maggie hassan in new
hampshire mark kelly in arizona cortez
masto in nevada you are partly
responsible for this you get the
donations from the teachers unions
warnock as well voters have to take note
of this your kids were locked out of
these schools for no reason congressman
it was all about keeping kids out of
schools laura so we're going to keep
hammering this thank you for doing this
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else